bomani jones back here on the show how
you doing sir
i'm good man how about you i'm better
than what the sixers must be going
through how's that for a transition to
start us off
i have a tendency to antagonize the
sixers loyalists because they had to
convince themselves that being
objectively terrible for a long time was
for the greater good
you know so they they're they're all in
on their team in a much different way
because i feel like people want a
certain measure of vindication
for buying into that travesty that they
got into and now here where they are
right
embiid's got this knee problem that like
i don't think that we're just talking
about something that's gonna be a thing
right now he's playing on a torn
meniscus like that's not a good
long-term thing to do
the other superstar talent that they
have is ben simmons and he seems
terrified of the idea of shooting in an
nba game which is kind of a weird thing
to say about an
nba player they gave 30 million dollars
to tobias harris
and he's just being tobias harris like
you should have played better than he
did yesterday but i mean i don't know
exactly what it is you think he's
supposed to get out of dubai's hair
and they really talk themselves into
like thinking that this was a team that
was going to win the championship but
who knows
it may be a disaster right now they
ultimately turn into champions but they
look like
bombs last night that is uh
a silva queen that i cannot argue a
single syllable
is off at all bomani and the way that
you started it is a perfect
way is that what what did you say that
being abjectly terrible
for a long time was for the greater good
that the trust the process
does it wind up with this being the end
result that requires
daryl mori to come in um you know
and and change things around from what
sam hinkey his friend
started like that may actually be the
bright shining
object in the room for the four sixers
to have to
deal with right now yeah so for me but
like
the hinky thing his tenure was
abbreviated and like you can't
it's easy to lump it all together and
then say like he's responsible for
markdale colts i don't even know who's
responsible for that to be perfectly
honest
but that's not on him he didn't draft
ben simmons but he would have drafted
ben simmons because we all would have
drafted
under the same circumstance correct but
the idea was we can get
you know the best way to do this is to
do this in order to get the caliber of
top-line talent
that is needed to win in the nba and
they got it except
embiid when they got him was an open box
special because he was hurt and has been
fairly consistently hurt
um for much of his career and then
simmons has
all the talent but there seems to be a
sort of block that stops him from
becoming the player that they need him
to be
in order for this team-building strategy
that they've used to work
so what happens i mean you can't
dispute also your analysis bomani jones
that
simmons looks like he's afraid to shoot
in an nba game
which is strange to say about an nba
player oh for one
in the second half of a game where you
know
they were killing it in the third
quarter and then couldn't
get anything done properly in the fourth
quarter that is
the ultimate and then also being a
liability on the court
to allow the hawks to get the
possessions they needed to get back
in the game because he can't make a free
throw i mean that's wild
the free throw thing is weird because
he's not the first person that we've
seen teams
intentionally put on the line right like
we saw it from shaq
obviously we've seen it from you know
dwight howard got it
yeah right then deandre jordan who's not
the same caliber player of these guys
that we're talking about but he wound up
on the business end of the same strategy
the thing that's interesting about all
those guys though that's different from
simmons is
they went up there and they were in
their heads
obviously when they were shooting the
free throws at times but it didn't seem
to affect everything else
and so with simmons the free throw thing
seems to spill over and then he doesn't
want to do anything
and then he's terrified of getting the
ball because then they're going to put
him on the line but the truth is
if you go and you hit one out of two
free throws
every time they do that that's actually
a win like if you can get one point per
possession on that
the teams aren't going to keep this up
but if you shoot four for 14
then i don't know why they tried
anything else i would have been trying
to find a free agent in the middle of
the game just to get six fouls
romani jones here on the rich eisen show
conversely though uh the performance by
paul george
uh i don't even know what if the word
unexpected
is proper to describe it what word do
you use to describe it
i'll go with unexpected i did not see
that coming and
something that i think is interesting to
think about with paul george
he was a number one option in indiana
and look they went game seven with those
heats like they had a legitimate chance
to go to
a nba finals i don't think they were
champions but he was the best player on
the team that was right there on the
doorstep
when he got to oklahoma city what was
interesting was that a guy like that was
so willing to play with a dominant
figure
like russell westbrook and actually had
his best season playing as a number two
but when they got to the playoffs he
wasn't a dude
that you could count on and it seems
weird that you
you might be able to better count on him
as the number one than the number two
like almost if he's the number two he's
like okay this other guy's got it
you know you don't really need too much
for me but they needed everything that
he gave them
right because that roster it really
stands out without kawhi when you look
at paul george and then see who else is
out there like that's not a team
that should win a game in the second
round of the playoffs except he
carried them and i've had all the jokes
about him and the playoff p
and everything else he earned all the
praise
from the way he performed in that game
which one do you expect to win a game
six more the bucks at home against the
nets
or or the clippers to close it out
against the jazz which one would you
choose if you had to choose only one
i am silly enough to believe that the
bucks are still going to win that series
hey kevin durant put in such a super
human performance in that game and
james harden basically was there like
they were playing 405
4 on 5 with him on the floor and that
was why buttonholzers it was such an
indictment of him
that nobody went out of their way to
attack
james harden and that hamstring when
chris paul went on that run in game four
against the nuggets
it was because they were relentlessly
attacking michael porter junior like
they had made the call this dude can't
guard anybody we're gonna
go at him at him at him and they didn't
do that in milwaukee
and so i still think that everything is
there for them to win that series just
because outside of kevin durant
the nets don't have anything but they
got to go inside and they got to play
like
their big people are big people because
if you really think about this series
the most underrated thing that milwaukee
has is there
the the nets literally have no one
capable of guarding brook lopez if they
just set him up on the block every
possession he gave him the ball
and they'll never do that and i don't
understand why he's 27 feet from the
basket but nobody could guard him he's
right next to it
that is a good point that is a good
point and
and then you know we had kendrick
perkins on the show yesterday he says
watch the nets bench
uh every time um giannis makes a jump
shot they're clapping because he's not
going to the rim
and yeah you know and so maybe just
maybe they do
get this thing straight and on the
straight and narrow and they force a
game seven
i i don't and then and then we'll see
obviously who who whoever wins that
series who they play next and
i kind of feel for the hawks because you
know we're we're a northeast in an east
coast biased
uh media and even though we're sitting
out here in los angeles by monty jones
but
uh the sixers you know disintegrating is
the story that everyone's talking about
and trey young
is doing what he's doing along with the
nate macmillan coach hawks can you put
in perspective
uh from your from your point of view
what trey young is doing right now
okay so i want to preface this by saying
that i grew up rooting
for the atlanta hawks and then that
ceased on february 24th
1994 when somebody got the bright idea
that trading the greatest player in the
history of your franchise for a couple
of months of danny manning was a good
idea
i left and i never came back and you
know what haven't missed them once
have not at all because what have the
hawks ever done to provide happiness for
their fan base
i don't recall seeing it at any point in
my life until now
like this is a fun team this is a team
that has weapons and trey young
even though i hate what i call his whole
insurance fraud
uh strategy of playing offense where
he's just jumping in front of you and
then slam it on the brakes so you can
run into him
he can get a settlement like you go to
his house you look in the closet there's
a bunch of neck braces for every time
that he has pulled
this little scam off but he
is so like the best thing about him and
ben simmons
being in this series allows you to see
what this contrast is if you were to ask
me which of those two guys i thought was
a better player i would tell you that
ben simmons is a better player just
because he's such an elite defender and
trey young is one of the worst defenders
in the league
however you get to this place wherever
you are in the postseason
and if you run a 6-0 run trey young can
decide that it's not going to be a 8-0
run like i'm going to come down here and
i'm going to get a bucket
you need a guy in the postseason who is
capable of doing that and he
is that dude and so for the hawks you
could go to some advanced numbers and
probably even find some guys on that
roster that might even qualify as being
better players than trey young
but nothing at this time is more
important than a guy when everybody else
is getting tight that can just say
all right boys i got this and everybody
look at him and say you know what he
probably does
and that's what he's been for them this
entire post he sure has been and i was
uh
i was uh preparing my audience at the
top of the show bomani jones that if
trey young advances
get ready for the take that the the
hawks were were right
to trade luca for him i'm getting
everyone prepared for that
hot take the money oh babe it's so funny
that people keep like relitigating that
trade and i feel like in sacramento they
got to be like yeah just don't talk
about us
like deandre ayton that seems to be
working out trey young
that seems to be working out right like
all you could hope for is
i would like for this thing to work out
and it's worked out for these guys
meanwhile marvin bagley's up there in
sacramento and ain't nothing working out
there i don't know if he's working out
like literally i have no idea if he's
lifting weights
bomani jones here uh on the rich eisen
show
how do you uh crystal ball it with aaron
rodgers how do you think that's going to
work
out uh i don't think he ain't going to
play for them again
like he seems so resolute on i don't
want to play for you guys anymore
and so the packers are going to have to
make the decision about
if they're willing to trade him and
where they're willing to trade him and
i'll be honest if i was the packers
it's not like there's going to be
another draft before the season starts
right like it's not like somebody's
going to be able to give you some
capital
that you can really use this season if
he says he wants to sit at the house
i would let him sit at the house but
they need to understand they blew this
they they somehow
did not know aaron rodgers as well as
the strangers no aaron rodgers and the
second that you made that pick
you made the move to the future and so
he made his move to the future and then
he messed around and had his best year
that he had and who knows how long
and now they want to keep him around
he's like nah man i'm good
and i bet he's willing to do the carson
palmer and go to the house
yeah i i i don't i don't know how
where where he where he winds up this
year then i don't see green bay trading
him it doesn't make sense to trade him
now
for assets that he's only going to
improve
um for for the team that that acquires
him
you know that's a great point and and
straightaway that first round pick
because of the 28.
well that's what i i'm saying is that
you know waiting for next year when
when the team that wants to acquire
rogers is
finished with their season of being
terrible that's a better draft pick for
green bay to acquire
then and i also don't see a better spot
for aaron rodgers to win now like the
places that might acquire him are not
tampa bay ready you know what i mean
they're i i don't
you know obviously rogers is talented
enough to do what brady did last year
which is to go to a new team and make it
his own fast and
but there still wouldn't even be an off
season to do that you know i i i don't
know what
palatable options there are for rogers
to win a super bowl
this year other than the the one of
going back to green bay
and then figuring out where he goes from
there i don't i just don't know bomani
you know yeah i i agree i don't i don't
see any easy
there's no team like you say there's no
team like tampa bay was
that is and aaron rodgers away from
being a super bowl contender that i can
think of that doesn't already have a
quarterback like i i just can't think of
who the team is
that's going to be that i am just
fascinated by the idea
that he is so sick of them and
coincidentally
so rich that if he wants to he can just
say
i'm not going to play for you guys right
period and just not show up and i wish i
was that free like when magic johnson
showed up that day and quit his job and
told us before he even told his boss
i was like man i wish i was that free i
would never do anything like that
but i would love to have that kind of
freedom and flexibility in my life just
be like i
just ain't doing this job and then move
on and aaron rodgers seems to be there
and at that place and
if that's how he feels like there's
nothing for us to say if he's willing to
give them back
millions of dollars to never play for
them then bless his heart and if i'm the
packers
he's going to have to show us that he's
willing to give us back millions of
dollars and if he is it might be
embarrassing to us
but i mean at least he minutes couple
more minutes left with bomani jones the
right time with bomani jones podcast
uh the espn uh host as well as
analyst here on the rich eisen show uh
27 years ago is when
oj hopped in that uh white ford bronco i
remember where i was where were you
on that exactly where i was up from
houston we were watching the game that's
right
and the next thing you do it was all on
the screen and i
am young enough that like i didn't fully
understand the magnitude of o.j simpson
like he was the broadcaster to me
right not you know the hero of an entire
generation
and it was just the strangest thing in
the world when the people were over
there it was like
the quote-unquote chase itself i didn't
find that to be so bizarre
it's when the people started showing up
at the overpass and keep in mind this
isn't like the internet era
you know we were operating on some
analog technology to people to find out
what was going on inside they wanted to
get their little moment of faith
and they were out there and man that
year and a half did not do good things
for america let me tell you
yeah i remember it was um rocket snicks
is what it was there's uh nba finals
rockets knicks right there in the middle
27 years ago and i remember
um you know they they they had a split
screen
um on on a game five of the nba finals
and on one screen was the was the bronco
and the other screen
and the other square was um was an
actual
big time nba finals basketball game with
hall of famers playing in it
you know future fans never forget this
part this is i think the easiest thing
to forget about that
he worked at nbc that's right at the
time
can you imagine that like they're
running the broadcast and your co-worker
is evading a murder charge it appears
while this is all going on
like i would have loved to see in the
email chain at nbc all right what in the
world are we about to do
yeah i was at i was at my post madeill
school of journalism graduate
uh graduation dinner with friends
in a chicago bar and just for you know
watson giggles
when the whole place was just standing
around the television set
and just like their jaws down on the
ground watching
the square with the white ford bronco i
was the knick fan screaming it was a
flagrant foul
and the stairs i got from people like
what the hell is your problem
um but it was fun you know that was just
my way of just kind of
breaking the tension because man it was
tense that is for sure
you know that was wild back in that day
27 years ago
bomani i always appreciate our
conversations um
let's uh i look for my call as we go
through these nba finals and throughout
the summer and
and beyond i really appreciate it no
problem man you guys have a good one
i really enjoy uh everything uh that
bomani jones brings to the table
whenever we have a conversation
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here